voilà mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir nous
allons revenir bien sûr tout au long de
cette édition sur l'actualité politique
ou sociale mais auparavant parce qu'il a
fait très beau en france aujourd'hui
vous vous en êtes rendu compte et aussi
parce qu'il est beaucoup question de
football sur antenne 2 je vous propose
de rester dans cette ambiance qui mêle
les sports et les loisirs
d'autant plus que cet après-midi un
certain nombre de sportifs de grand
talent nous ont offert des spectacles
étonnants
il y a le tennis avec un formidable
match entre arthur ashe et yann kodesh
lors des internationaux de france à
roland garros et puis à colombes
et c'est par là que nous allons
commencer les spectateurs présents au
stade yves du manoir mais aussi les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 ont pu
suivre l'une des plus belles rencontres
de rugby de cette année c'était la
finale du challenge yves du manoir elle
opposait béziers à narbonne
score final 19 à 19 mai au bénéfice des
essais tu sais narbonne qui l'emportent
mais béziers menaient 19 à 3 à la
mi-temps a fait une formidable remontée
en seconde mi-temps bilan exceptionnel
en effet entre narbonne et béziers qui
joue à gauche votre écran sur cette
action trallero récupère la balle puis
ramon qui passa par yes et c'est le
premier essai marqué au pied des poteaux
essai non transformé narbonne 4 vézier 0
à la sortie de cette mêlée l'action se
développe successivement entre ramon le
9 pariès le dispense aux lots 6 rames
ont à nouveau et c'est sale est numéro 2
qui marquait la 18e minute le deuxième
essai narbonnais essai transformé par
paris yes narbonne 10 dédié 0 après une
pénalité réussie par cabrol qui donne
ses trois premiers points béziers sur
une interception de pailhès ponceau
pousse à suivre et ramon marque la 33e
minute minutes le 33e le troisième essai
narbonnais un essai dans paris y est ce
encore vive à réussir la transformation
score à la mi temps narbonne 16 béziers
iii on joue maintenant seconde mi temps
après une pénalité réussie par pariès
pour narbonne sur une balle sans type
arras pour espérer suivre say say qui
marque le premier essai pour béziers
cabrol sur la transformation narbonne
19/10 oeuf cabrol réussit ensuite deux
pénalités pour béziers au 47e et 55e
minute narbonne 19 et béziers 15 et à la
70e minute sur cette mêlée ouverte et
speg sort la balle pour fêter ses vingt
l'effet qu'une essai qui ne sera pas
transformé
narbonne 19 béziers 19 le score ne
changera plus mais le règlement fera la
différence salle du rugby donc avec
beaucoup d'essais du rugby comme roger
couderc l'apprécient mais notre ami
roger qui était à colombes cet après
midi et qui m me presqu'autant le tennis
le rugby a raté quelque chose
d'exceptionnel à roland garros un match
de tennis comme on en voit peu opposant
deux très grands champions
l'américain arthur h et le tchèque jan
kodes esch le central de roland garros
était archi-plein
à 35 ans arthur h s'est encore
émerveillé le public est à 32 ans ian
kodesh a toujours ses jambes de 20 ans
ce match de vieux routier des courts de
tennis a certainement été le meilleur
que l'on ait vue depuis le début des
internationaux de france
un véritable plaisir pour les yeux une
leçon de tennis les spectateurs ne
manquez pas 14000 dans les gradins du
court central le tchécoslovaque qui
prenait les choses en main dans le
premier set il gagnait pijesak 15 mai
après ce fut un festival offert par le
noir américain 6 3 au deuxième set 7 6
au troisième et enfin 6 4 dans le set
décisif
arthur ashe accède donc en huitièmes de
finale des internationaux de france pour
un homme qui n'est pas particulièrement
à l'aise sur la terre battue puis s'est
donné pour but cette année de gagner le
tournoi de wimbledon sur herbe et qui
revient à roland garros après plusieurs
années d'absence la performance
dans le match suivant qui oppose en ce
moment même l'argentin guillermo vilas
au jeune français yannick noah est ou
non vous dont nous voyons ici les images
du premier set
les choses sont plus simples pas
question a priori pour noah d'espérer
battre villa ce dernier vainqueur de
l'épreuve lui résister tout au mieux et
dans le premier set l'argentin a
d'ailleurs mis les choses au point
il a facilement gagné 6 jeux à 2 et dans
le deuxième set yannick noah a accompli
un petit exploit en s'imposant 6 jeux à
le résultat de ce match entre nos rêves
il as peut-être avant la fin de cette
édition et puis durant ce week-end il ya
aussi ceux qui tentent d'aller vraiment
au delà des limites humaines les
coureurs de strasbourg paris pour suivre
leur randonnée
ils sont attendus demain après midi vers
16 heures à nogent sur marne cette
édition est la cinquante deuxième du
genre cette année le départ a été donné
à mutzig
il y a une chose que je voudrais dire
tout plu aux spectateurs qui ont
peut-être un peu tendance à qu'ils ont
une blague et les marcheurs de
strasbourg paris il faut les avoir vus
de près les avoir suivis pour affirmer
que l'on devrait leur élever une statue
parfaitement à cause du long calvaire
qu'ils endurent trois jours et trois
nuits et croyez moi pas pour l'argent
la récompense est un bon à valoir dans
un magasin d'articles ménagers
alors vous voyez il n'y a pas de quoi
courir regardez les bien il marche il me
l'ont dit pour le plaisir
alors messieurs de strasbourg paris chat
pour chapeau aux luxembourgeois josy
simon 45 ans déjà vainqueur trois fois
de l'épreuve qui a une heure trente
d'avancé sur le belge emile alomene 53
ans lui est un peu plus sur le champion
de l'an dernier robert shoken chapeau
aussi à tout ce vous l'avez vu qu'ils
n'arriveront pas demain jusqu'à nogent
sur marne
et puis rendez-vous à stade de demain
pour voir quand même un peu plus d'image
chapeau 1 défaite voilà pour l'actualité
sportive de cette journée je ne
reviendrai pas sur la coupe du monde de
football puisque une émission spéciale
lui sera consacré à la fin de ce journal
les affaires sociales renault la
direction de la régie à a contre attaqué
lundi on saura si le tribunal autorise
l'évacuation par la force publique si
nécessaire d usine de cléon et de flins
actuellement occupé par quelques
centaines de grévistes
la régie a également décidé de fermer
pour trois jours c'est à dire jusqu'à
jeudi matin
lusine de flat parallèlement à ces
actions sur le terrain donc la régie
renault poursuites en justice un certain
nombre de délégués ou bien de membres du
personnel est enfin là suspendu toutes
les négociations en cours avec les
syndicats
ce matin les usines de flins et de cléon
étaient toujours occupées les grilles
étaient fermées et personne ne pouvait
entrer à l'intérieur des usines pour les
syndicats l'objectif est de reprendre
les négociations
la cgc c'est à dire les cadres font
appel à la responsabilité et au bon sens
de toutes les parties en présence
la cgt de son côté réaffirme sa volonté
de reprendre à tout moment les
négociations voit l'heure actuelle dans
les usines ce qui prédomine c'est le
calme
les 300 grévillers 300 occupants aupr s
occuper visiblement leurs ateliers
il faut que la direction ramène des
propositions n'a pas encore voulu amener
une seule proposition c'est pas possible
de bloquer la production comme elle le
fait de prendre la responsabilité de
rater le lancement de la r18 comme elle
le fait actuellement
tout ça sur un refus de bloquer les
d'arrêter les négociations parce qu'il
ya un conflit secteur sera secteur qui
touche 600 mo/s et c'est la question
l'ouverture des négociations pour la cgt
c'est le problème principal aujourd'hui
lundi et mardi une conférence sur les
moyens économiques mais aussi militaires
à prendre pour assurer la stabilité en
afrique se réunira à paris une
conférence qui réunira les principaux
pays occidentaux ont nés d'unions ni
étudiera les problèmes du développement
du continent africain
mais on parlera aussi beaucoup des
récents événements au zaïre en
mauritanie ou bien au tchad
les combats qui viennent d'avoir lieu
dans le centre est du tchad ont mis ces
derniers jours en valeur l'importance de
l'engagement militaire français dans ce
pays d'après les chiffres émanant de
sources sérieuses les combats autour de
dja dame aurait mobilisé du côté
français
environ 300 hommes du côté du frolinat
on annonce que 58 militaires français
auraient été tués des informations de
toute évidence absolument faux selon le
ministère de la défense aucun militaire
français n'aurait été tué seul un avion
jaguar a été abattu le pilote a pu être
récupérés sains et saufs les
parachutistes français qui sont
intervenus au zaïre quittons ce pays à
partir de mercredi
selon l'elysée c'est parra seront
relevés par les troupes venues du maroc
du sénégal et peut-être d'autres pays
d'afrique mais ce matin à calvi se sont
déroulées les obsèques de cinq
légionnaires tués lors des combats de
kolwezi
une foule immense assistaient à cette
cérémonie plus de 2000 personnes
drapé de tricolore les cinq cercueils
avaient été alignés devant le monument
aux morts de la légion dans son homélie
l'archiprêtre de calvi a longuement
exalté le courage de ces hommes partis
en afrique
dans un souci plus humanitaire que par
idée de guerre les uns légionnaires ont
été décoré à titre posthume de la
médaille militaire et de la croix de la
valeur militaire avec palme la politique
pour la première fois depuis l'échec de
la gauche aux élections le parti
communiste organise aujourd'hui et
demain un grand rassemblement populaire
il s'agit de la fête annuelle du
mouvement de la jeunesse communiste de
france les organisateurs y attendent
plus de cent mille personnes
lors de cette fête il a été et il sera
beaucoup question de la politique du
gouvernement du chômage mais aussi des
interventions françaises en afrique mais
la discussion qui se déroule au sein du
parti communiste français depuis sa
défaite du mois de mars va aussi se
traduire dans de nombreux débats certes
les grands contestataires ne seront pas
là mais on voit mal comment demain lors
de son discours monsieur georges
marchais pourrait ne pas évoquer la
situation qui se développe au sein du
pcf
avant le discours de monsieur marche s
est donc aujourd'hui la fête les
funambules léo ferré ce soir les
orchestres et fanfares les manèges c'est
aussi les rencontres et débats sur
l'actualité politique le chômage des
jeunes l'avenir de l'union de la gauche
ceux qui critiquent le parti communiste
de l'intérieur ne sont pas là ou en
petit nombre
louis althusser et jean l'einstein ne
sont pas venus parce qu'on ne souhaitait
pas qu'il devienne question là mais la
fête cette question quelques individus
qui contestent la politique du êtes
aussi c'était la ronde et l'immense
majorité des jeunes qui sont là qui sont
là pour débattre avec les communistes
qui sont là dans la volonté que ça
change et qui reconnaissent les
communistes comme ceux qui sans force de
proposition comme ceux qui les aident
le débat a été reprise et pas la
discussion c'est également avec ceux qui
contestent la discussion et les stands
d'avant garde et douce et les fans de
carnets où tous les jeunes quels qu'ils
soient pas venir poser leurs questions
pourtant quelques étudiants
contestataires de bordeaux ont installé
un stand il y vendent le livre critique
du pc de louis althusser
ils se promènent doit aussi au milieu de
la fête et c'est l'occasion d'engager
spontanément un dialogue
malgré cela il est vrai que l'énorme
majorité des jeunes communistes ils sont
venus à ivry est adopté la politique
d'hier les gens du parti tout en
estimant que leur mouvement possède son
indépendance et dans notre fédération
notre lutte avec nous les décideurs
politiques
ceci dit je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui compris une forte
réprobation et les jeunes communistes
sont exacerbées par la campagne qui est
menée pour affaiblir les communistes et
pour diviser les communistes le grand
moment de la fête des jeunes communistes
aura lieu demain vers 4 heures de
l'après midi le secrétaire général du
parti georges marchais ne prononcera pas
un discours banal de bienvenue et
d'encouragement il tiendra à dissiper un
malaise et a démontré que la majorité
communiste est largement derrière lui et
ceci quelques jours avant la prochaine
réunion du comité central du pc
du côté de la majorité les clubs
perspectives et réalités tenait une
réunion nationale actuellement 300 clubs
perspectives et réalités existe en
france il regrouperait plus de 50000
personnes et ils sont plus spécialement
chargé au sein de l'udf de l'animation
doctrinale et aussi de la réflexion à
long terme sur quel thème va maintenant
porter cette réflexion la réponse de
jean pierre fourcade qui a été réélu
président des clubs perspectives et
réalités
nous allons nous lancer dans trois
domaines de réflexion
d'abord la politique européenne
car les élections européennes de l'année
prochaine sont un objectif très
important pour la france et nous avons
décidé de consacrer les travaux de notre
prochaine convention qui aura lieu le 18
novembre prochains à strasbourg aux
problèmes européens n'ont pas pour
relancer une guerre de religion en
matière d'europe mais pour essayer de
voir concrètement ce que les
institutions européennes peuvent
apporter pour résoudre les problèmes de
la vie quotidienne de chacun de nos
concitoyens
deuxième thème de réflexion c'est
évidemment celui des problèmes de
réduction des injustices et des
inégalités dans notre société c'est le
thème central du programme de gloire
c'est un thème sur lesquels il faut à la
fois être lucide et courageux car
l'examen des injustices et des
inégalités risque de poser quelques
difficultés à beaucoup de français ou de
catégories française il est important de
les connaître des recensés et c'est
pourquoi
partant du rapport de jacques méreau de
l'année dernière nous avons entamé ce
thème de réflexion
enfin en troisième lieu le troisième
thème c'est un thème qui est beaucoup
plus profond très difficile à traiter
que monique pelletier a introduit devant
nous c'est le thème des problèmes de
sécurité dans un état démocratique
jusqu'où peut-on aller dans la
répression comment faut-il organiser la
prévention
quelles doivent être les rapports entre
la justice et la police dans un état
démocratique
à cinq jours de l'arrivée en corse de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing dix
personnes ont été interpellées par la
police dans l'île de beauté dix
personnes qui sont accusées d'avoir
utilisé l'explosif pour défendre leurs
opinions politiques
quelques-unes d'entre elles auraient
déjà reconnu leur participation à
plusieurs attentats et notamment à celui
qui a détruit le 13 août dernier un
relais de télévision
la corse avait alors été privés d'image
cependant de l'ombre en prévision en
tout cas de ce voyage du chef de l'état
en corse 2000 crs et gendarmes ont été
envoyés en renfort le double meurtre de
mougins c'est probablement un familier
qui a fait le coup pour les policiers il
fallait en effet connaître bien les
habitudes de la maison pour savoir où se
trouvait le coffre murale qui a disparu
en tout cas ce couple de retraités
britanniques qui occupait cette maison à
mougins a été tué à bout portant par les
projectiles d'un fusil de chasse
les policiers ignorent encore le motif
de ce double crime de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on connaît bien sûr la
grande série mais on aime aussi le cousu
main et ce même dans le domaine de
l'automobile philippe chattem aux
etats-unis est tombé nez à nez si je
puis dire avec l'une des voitures les
plus étonnantes de notre époque c'est
fabricant n'en sortent que 5 par mois
pratiquement à la mesure du client des
images insolites donc des états unis où
malgré la crise de l'énergie
le culte de la belle voiture existe
encore et où certains n'hésitent pas à
dépenser 45 mille dollars et pratique
deux millions de centimes pour ne pas
avoir la voiture de monsieur tout le
monde la nouvelle ds de ce culte la
voici la clé n'est 220 chevaux plus de 8
litres de cylindrée fabriquée
entièrement à la main sur commande
seulement rien n'est trop beau pour la
clé n'est 16 couches de peinture
intérieure cuir et agneaux retourner
tableau de bord en noyer anglais et même
regarder le cendrier est en cristal de
lalique la clé n'est représente sans
doute ce qui se fait de plus exclusifs
mais aussi le plus cher presque quarante
cinq mille dollars
plus de deux cent vingt mille francs et
pourtant elle se vend
c'est ici dans un ancien hangar d'avion
à santa barbara que les clés né sont
fabriqués à partir des éléments
mécaniques et du châssis du nikon la
carrosserie est en acier assemblé à la
main chaque voiture demande 1700 heures
de travail alors qu'une voiture
américaine de série n'en prend que 10
heures au début ici il n'y avait que six
employés aujourd'hui deux ans plus tard
il y à 70 artisans qui fabriquent cinq
voitures par mois
entièrement à la main chaque voiture
vendue porte sur une plaque d'argent
les noms des artisans qui l'ont créée
qui sont personnellement responsables de
la qualité de leur travail et qu'ils en
sont fiers le père de cette belle
californienne le voici
alain clénay 33 ans un français venu aux
états unis il ya neuf ans travaille à
détroit comme styliste et qui maintenant
voudrait devenir le rôle de ross
amérique
il faut regarder le marché il faut
regarder les possibilités financières de
st et puis fondre faire le grand
plongeon
on se retrouve à dessiner une voiture de
luxe
et pourquoi une voiture de luxe parce
qu'il faut par principe ne pas
concurrencer détroit au point de vue
prix et ne pas conclure concurrence et
détroit au point de vue produit avec
tout ça en tête on dessine une voiture
qui n'est pas une voiture de course une
voiture de sport parce qu'avec une
limitation de vitesse à 55 milles
on ne peut pas vraiment faire une
voiture très attrayante qu'elle est la
seule façon de faire une voiture qui
soit attrayante c'est de faire une
voiture élégante
ce qui est très important c'est de
produire quelque chose de très exclusive
est ce que vous pensez qu'une pareille
réussite aurait été possible en france
non je ne pense pas parce que
l'ouverture de marchés n'y est pas la
situation politique en france et en
europe en général le permet pas une
telle aventure
les états unis ouvre le marché qui est à
mon avis mme way 20 à 50 fois le marché
français et sur ce produit
spécifiquement sur ce produit je crois
que c'est au moins dix fois le marché
européen total malgré la crise de
l'énergie malgré les limitations de
vitesse malgré les préoccupations
écologiques
malgré la fortune que coûte une telle
voiture l'automobile et surtout
l'automobile de luxe reste un élément
essentiel du style de vie des américains
ah si riche pour conduire une clé n'est
et des rêves des autres américaine voilà
pour terminer ce journal j'aurais pu
maintenant vous dire retour au football
retour à la coupe du monde mais vous
savez cette coupe du monde de football
qui se déroule en argentine se déroule
dans un pays où journellement sont
oubliées les plus élémentaires droits de
l'homme et cela pose des problèmes qui
ne sont plus des problèmes sportifs hier
soir patrick poivre d'arvor vous
l'annonçait la police argentine a essayé
de saisir un reportage tourné par l'une
de nos équipes à reportage où il n'était
certes pas question de sport richard
diot et jean françois renaud avait voulu
rencontrer il y a deux jours celle khan
officier argentin appelé aujourd'hui les
folles de la place de mai ces folles ce
sont les maires ou les compagnes de
disparus qui depuis six mois ont pris
l'habitude de se rassembler chaque jeudi
devant le palais présidentiel
en dépit de la réaction de la police
argentine les envoyés spéciaux ont pu
nous faire parvenir cet après-midi les
images qu'ils ont tourné jeudi
alors je vous propose d'écouter ces
témoignages c'est l'autre face de la
coupe du monde
tous les jeudis matins et tous les
jeudis et plein de police
et aujourd'hui c'est la première fois
qu'il n'ya pas du tout de cela six
médias ne pas sonner on sent la patte
rouge et l'eau dévale iphone las casas
génomique del cine les pertes à
l'embellie à caracas a été hissé la gv
alors à séoul à nyon items mais c'est
nous pourrait abaisser à miami marilyn
au salon ifa si l on sait qu éclate non
roms à la casse à nice et jenny cgv
alarcon sauver la caravane à la peau
tannée micasa en dévalisant de la casbah
particulièrement mesure iv la pinède
reviennent à la famille de l'austérité
est à noter que nikos savez morgan and
is everything active et de surveillance
le centre enquête amorcée en argentine à
y sommes sortis ne les connais moi ce
cellulaire et cet avis viennent dans mon
champ d'honneur moutier triste et ça me
tient en outre à caresser les régions
devenant les 8 10 ans pour que nous
sommes certains dans la matrice ya dans
nos marques et vivent à l'ouest sont
alarmants réduite aussi fausses comme
bastia pour qui veut ça mais mona dans
des chaussettes en vive hausse au moins
dans certaines fermes c'est ainsi
soufflé fuyons cnn à murray hill et ses
opérations pour des annonces à bien me
soigner le membre et courir
en argentine il n'y a pas que le
football
elle me viens de vous dire qu'il a fait
beau aujourd'hui sur toute la france il
a fait vous il ya surtout fait très
chaud à 17 heures cet après midi le
thermomètre market encore 29° à biarritz
encore que sur ma petite carte je vois
qu'il est indiqué 27 degrés mais là
c'était à 14 heures la température a
monté depuis
et vous voyez les autres températures
très élevées encore pour ce début du
mois de juin
demain les spécialistes nous promettent
en revanche cela en argentine
il n'y a pas que le football et je me
souviens de vous dire qu'il a fait beau
aujourd'hui sur toute la france il a
fait beau il a surtout fait très chaud à
17 heures cet après midi le thermomètre
market encore 29° à biarritz encore que
sur ma petite carte je vois qu'il est
indiqué 27 degrés mais là c'était à 14
heures la température a monté depuis
et vous voyez les autres températures
très élevées encore pour ce début du
mois de juin demain les spécialistes
nous promettent en revanche attend plus
médiocres de l'aquitaine à la bretagne
ils nous annoncent un ciel le plus
souvent nuageux avec des pluies
intermittentes et parfois quelques
orages sur le reste du pays après une
matinée souvent nuageuse le soleil fera
son apparition les températures
changeront peu par rapport à celles
d'aujourd'hui
voilà cette édition un peu tardive est
maintenant terminée
à 23h50 environ ces pirates qui vous
donnera les dernières informations de ce
samedi quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à 13 heures bonne soirée sur
antenne 2